موقع Voda Baccano op
أنا أفعل ذلك من هذا القبيل
[موسيقى]
اه 3 ، الإعداد أعلاه هو المكان الذي يتم فيه تركيز القطن الذي جاء للأمام على اليد
فترة
قام وزير الخارجية الأمريكي غونغ يو مايكو بونكير ورفاقه بزيارة كوريا في 9 مايو.
زار رسميا
[موسيقى]
نعم ، في مطار صنع في إنجلترا ، تم تعيين نائب الرئيس السابق كيم هيونغ تشيول.
وزير الخارجية سيضمن أومجي الرسمي أنه فقد الرفيق سون
فيما يلي ما فعله كوجا ييجا: وزير الخارجية الأمريكي يرحب بلام ، والأصفر
تم إرشادهم
[موسيقى]
أوه أوه
افتتاحية القدر هو امتداد ، رئيس مصطنعة تشو مين وجومي الاحتياطي أون جانغ الجديد
يجب علينا إنقاذ حزبنا والوطن ، التخلي عنه
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أونج وونج ، الذي زار كوريا بعد ظهر اليوم التاسع لحضور 18 امرأة جالسة في الدور التمهيدي.
كان من المؤسف أن يتم خلط بيرة ميكو فورم.
[موسيقى]
آه
الرفيق الصدفة غير المتعلم Doja ،
مسابقة Maiko Poom Viewer رحبت ترحيبا حارا بالزواج ، وقبل فترة ، المتاهة
قال مان إنه رسمي ، لكن مبروك على السلطعون.
11 0 0 درجة من الحجر الصحي
نرحب ترحيبا حارا ، كما تعلم ، كان من المؤسف أن ألتقط الصور معه ومع كيم يونغ.
السيد شل قال أيضا أن السيد جاو كان مع وزيرة الخارجية الأمريكية ، والتالية
آسف لقول
[موسيقى]
في حالة الفصل 9 من Mycom Pierce ، سأقوم تلقائيًا بإلقاء نظرة على الجريمة ، ارتفاع الرئيس
توصيل الرسالة مباشرة وتمهيد الطريق لسومي خلال محادثات الترتيب
بقول أنك زرت ، خذ وقتًا بعيدًا عن جدولك المزدحم
فعلت
أوو
مايك بوم بيركر على Seo-woo
في الوقت الحالي ، خطيئة الإنكار هي أيضًا تلقائية ، وزير الخارجية مايك بومبيو والرماة المحليون
لا توجد كتابات تهم الجزر الثلاث.
موقف ورأي القيادة الكورية العليا فيما يتعلق بقمة Ye Som-yi Soon-i السابقة
أنا آسف للجنرال
[موسيقى]
خطيئة التجربة ، القائد الرفيق ،
الألقاب الذين انشقوا وكسبوا أيديهم يعقدون لم الشمل والمحادثات
وقالت إن الخزف الدائري الرفيق شوير تحدث مع وزير الخارجية 595 حول قضايا بوليد.
لقد رأيت الكثير من حرارة غرب الكرمل
[موسيقى]
5 Kyungmin Discount Shell Beongyeongdo Automatic Stew 30
من خلال إضافة العمل المعادي للشيوعية لإغلاق الأمريكيين الذين ليسوا في القانون في بلدنا
من أجل إطلاق
يكاد يكون محارًا حقيقيًا لشهر يناير في ثكنات الولايات المتحدة
جوسول جمهورية أوغومو الديمقراطية الشعبية أمر اللجنة Mionzan ، إلخ. التاريخ
يرجى تنفيذها والصلاة من أجلها.
[موسيقى]
ميا هي رفيقة شل بوريونغ دوجا وزيرة الخارجية في الطبخ بيو ، الأمر الأكثر وضوحًا
5 الذين تكلموا
هل حققت خطى مرضية؟